hello everyone a lot of you have been
asking me to show you some of my own
games and while I am looking forward to
showing you some of my better games and
some of my terrible games I didn't move
a lot in the past two years I changed
like four or five apartments I think
this is the fifth so I don't really I
don't really know where my games are but
they are somewhere and I will find them
so so I will make some videos about my
earlier games but until that happens I
decided to show you one game I played
that was played in 2011 it was played in
split in Croatia it was the split open
tournament and it was played in the
first round me and Yann Almighty and
myself we went to split to play this
tournament and we had we had the free
accommodations I asked my friend if we
could stay at her place and she said no
problem but there's only one catch she
won't be there she's going to London and
I said so we get the apartment for
ourselves and she said yes but my
grandma will also be there so I grabbed
a bottle of rakia for the grandma and we
went to split
we went there you know she we settled in
and we came to the first round and in
the first round I saw I was playing
against agnia ogonek Grandmaster from
Croatia and I didn't really have time to
prepare for the game as this is round
one they just showed the pairings and
the round is starting so I had the black
pieces and again opened the game with d4
so as I didn't have time to prepare and
luckily I was pretty happy he played d4
in 94 cents I did cover d4 defence is
much better than e4 so I play Knight to
f6 he played c4 and I played c5 I went
for the benoni defense he played d5 and
I played ecigs we have Knight to c3
I played eight characters on d5 C
captors on d5 and d6 I went for a for g6
I prepared Bishop to g7 and he played f4
this is the pawn storm variation of the
Benoni
I played Bishop to g7 and he immediately
played Bishop to b5 check and I wasn't
really glad I thought
move since I didn't really know how to
play this variation I knew that if I
played something like Bishop to Bishop
to d7 blocking or Knight to d7
I have to be ready for the move e5 for
example if I play Knight to d7 to block
you can go a five and after something
like ad captures F captures Knight to h5
Knight to f3
I could Castle from maybe Bishop g5 this
position is a playable for black but he
has this beautiful Center and you know
all of his pieces are beautifully placed
I didn't know this variation so I
decided not to go for it and the one
other thing as he decided to go for it
that's the main reason I decided to not
go for it
so after Bishop to b5 check I play
Knight F to d7 and I didn't really have
a problem with this since I read in in a
book I have opening theory by Borislav
Eve Cove that night after d7 is also
perfectly fine so he played Knight to f3
I castled here now my knight isn't
pinned I can move it he cancelled as
well and I played a6 and I was very very
happy at this point I managed to play a
six castle safely my bishop is on this
beautiful diagonal and after he moves
the bishop I am planning to push b5
which is something I always enjoy
because most of the times I played a
Benoni white pushes a4 and he stops my
Queen side expansion so he played Bishop
to d3 and I immediately pushed b5 with
some ideas of course of playing before
but he stopped this immediately with a
three I went to Queen to e7 preparing to
bring the rook into the game and he
played h3 now c4 I expand even further
around the Queen side kicking the bishop
back and now I play tonight to c5 making
room for my other night on d7 and also
now he has to be he has to be careful
about my knight jumping to b3 or d3 at
some point if if he allows it
he played rook to e1 he is definitely
preparing to push a 5 at some point and
I played Knight B to d7 now controlling
a5 once more with the knight Knight to
d4 and
here okay he's maybe threatening to jump
to c6 but although it is a good square
for the night once my queen moves it's
the night that doesn't really have
anything to do there I'm just gonna play
Bishop e7 either capture it you'll have
to go back so I could play there should
be seven here or maybe even Rocky eight
but I decided to go for Queen to h4
since he allowed it and I felt that
there was a lot of a lot of draft to
there on the dark squares so I thought
my queen could be useful on h4 he could
of course simply play Knight back to f3
I would simply play a queen back to d8
so you know if he decides to waste a
move I don't mind wasting a move and the
other thing is I have this beautiful
dark square Bishop and g7 so I don't
know I kind of like my queen on h4 he
played Bishop to e3 he continued
developing and here I played Knight rook
to e8 if I played it I mean like maybe I
could have played something like nice to
have six but then again I I I mean I
couldn't he'd simply go a five and this
is great for him so rook to e8 I control
the e-file even more with the rook and
he played Queen to d2 probably with some
ideas of 'if I've or f5 maybe after he
kicks the Queen away would Knight to f3
go Bishop to h6 anything is possible I
guess
I played Bishop to b7 he played Knight
back to f3 now kicking my queen and I
happily went back Queen to d8 he played
Bishop to b4 now and this is another
case where I trust my opponent as the
strongest move in this position is to
capture the bishop on d4 but I never
even considered this move I thought I'm
playing against the Grandmaster Bishop
captures Queen captures this will be
excellent for him but after Bishop
captures Queen captures I can simply
play something like Queen to b6 and now
I'm definitely threatening to exchange
some pieces for example e5 doesn't
really work here I have D captures F
capture send Knight to b3 now forcing
the exchange of Queens and some more
pieces for example Bishop captures queen
character's Knight captures pawn
captures and there's a pretty while
position here I have a passport and III
he has a passed pawn on d5 also a nice
bone on e5 but that one is currently
attacked so for example ecigs
pawn captures rook captures and it's a
wild position but definitely playable
for both the white and black and this is
just one of the variations that could
have arise but you know I didn't even
consider capturing on d4 since he's a
grandmaster
so I played Bishop to h6 I thought okay
I'm gonna stop he five indirectly by
pinning your f4 pawn since your queen is
on d2 and you know I might have some
ideas with Knight to e5 to exchange some
pieces again you can't capture because
the pawn is pinned and he played Knights
to d1 and I remember when I was playing
this game I was really I got really
nervous when he played Knight 2 d1 as
you know so I'm playing against the
Grandmaster I'm really called fading and
watching what what's he gonna do and I
never even considered night 2 d1 and
then I started seeing ideas like tonight
f2 comes to g4 attacks my bishop on e6
my bishop has to go back for example to
g7 then I just wasted the move you know
making my whole Bishop h6 idea terrible
I'll probably have to go to f8 but then
he has some ideas of f5 night h6 check I
so I was very unhappy when I saw this
and III had continued the game I played
rook to c8 I played rope to c8 with the
idea of playing Knight to b3 attacking
the Queen and the bishop so he will have
to capture with the light square Bishop
I will capture with the C pawn and then
I will create a I thought I would create
a nice outpost for my rook on C - he
played nice - f2 and now he is
definitely preparing night at g4 and
here I thought a lot about playing
Knight to e5 and this this is in fact
the best move but I I constantly thought
that I'm playing against the Grandmaster
you know there is no way I can play 95
he probably has discovered but after 95
94 Knight captures H captures I do have
the option for example playing f6 and
maybe I can hold this
you know let's be clear he would
probably beat me if we played any of
these variations I've shown but you know
by not playing what I thought he wanted
to play my position deteriorated even
faster than it then maybe should have so
after night f2 I didn't go for 95 I
played what I had you know planned this
night the B 3 move attacking the Queen
and the bishop on d4 he captured I
captured and although now it seems like
I do have a nice outpost for my rook on
c2 he simply plays Knight to g4 and I
don't have time for any of these ideas
he's threatening to capture the bishop
so what do I play here I play Bishop to
f8 and really there is no better move I
could go
I could go Bishop g7 but it would be the
same in the end he played f5 now opening
up Queens reach to h6 and I didn't
really know what to play here if I play
something like rook to c2 that really
makes no sense in simply plays Knight to
h6 check and I don't have any squares
for my King I have to capture Queen
captures threatening his threatening
checkmate on g7 I'd have to block this
and after Knight to g5 again threatening
to capture on h7 now I don't have a way
to stop this after something like Queen
to f6 the to stop checkmate at least he
could capture King f8 and now after
Queen to h4 he's threatening Knight - h7
forking the king and the Queen rook f1
is coming which f captures on g6 this is
completely winning for white you know so
it's a it's an excellent position for
white so after f5 I seem to play Bishop
back to g7 as I didn't really find any
any playable move
he played Bishop captures I played King
captures and he simply played Queen to
h6 check King back to g8 was played and
he played Knight to g5 and now as you
can see there is very little I can do
here I did play Knight f6 to control h7
he captured I captured and after rook to
f1 I was forced to resign the game as
there
there is no good defense against Knight
captures night and if I capture the
knight or something then he has a clear
for example my captors he has a clear
queen h7 can give faith and queen to f7
checkmate so there after this rook to f1
there is really nothing black can do
here with best defense it's checkmate in
six moves so yeah that's that's the game
first game from from split opening 2011
I played against only new on each
Croatian Grandmaster and you know I
thought it'd be somewhat educational to
show you this game simply because you
you have to trust yourself if your
opponent offers something it's you know
always trust yourself regardless of what
you think your opponent knows and I'd
probably lose this game well you know
regardless of what we played but it
would have been a more impressive game
if I played what I had initially
initially intended to play so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I will find those games
you know that there are my girlfriend's
actually packed them in some some you
know safety papers so I don't lose them
so they are somewhere I just have to
find them where they are as there are a
lot of interesting games there so thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon